hey guys my name is Joey and once again
we have some injustice to gameplay for
you all this one is coming from nether
realm stream where they highlighted
Harley Quinn's moveset and gear options
any comic book outfits you'd like to see
make it into the game
let me know in the comments and be sure
to subscribe for more in justice to
videos Hydra is approaching first we're
gonna start off with showing some of the
stuff that's new with Harley yes sure
her core based gameplay is very similar
if you liked how she played a part one a
lot a lot of carryover she's still kind
of an annoying gnat of a toy Catherine I
hit on characters her gods are very very
good other great a lot we've been
missing the best rate extracting a lot
more than he should be
absolutely so it's really good probably
in some kind of talk about just two
general kinds of design philosophy was
alluring characters and that is that we
want the players who play Harley you'll
get get the control of their hand and
have a good idea what the game plan is
right we've added some stuff kind of
change up heaven yes she has one of her
new combo
you just from that though athletes
overhead and then if they fully hit you
get the whole package in there and
that's a really good travel under like
you can do it a factory or you can use
it as a mix up all the recurring
character useful to have to throw he has
a new option tantrum fresh size across
and dynamite right you can actually you
don't need to necessarily be right on or
next to your home to do it with great
example whoops
so it's got a little bit of distance on
it too which is nice as like a lay down
projectile in addition to your cartwheel
and your blazing gun right now what I
really like about Harley - can you show
that the baseball bat again
yes alright character for example I'm
showing the farm party I love a little
personality that she goes back and she
had hundreds events yes what else well
she bolts them from the Phantom Zone
down here exactly yeah
of heart can they have like a fifth
pocket don't know it's and most of her
moves come back she floods the cupcake
bombs she still has the air gun shot
straight gunshot you interesting Arobin
I don't judge yes hon this time we will
congestus tidbit
well well normally when you do a special
move you cannot immediately go into
another special new but hardly actually
came so you can see she can do the
anti-air gunshot and immediately input a
straight gunshot and the recovery of the
air gunshot will end and she'll go
straight to comes yeah so that allows
for gunshots to come out faster than
normal
any of those people you know a lot of
people get kind of scared when they see
a character that maybe use its owning a
lot yeah but the thing about her like
you said she it's an annoyance it's like
you have to be patient right I don't
because I'm simply kind of damage
yeah the point of the gunshot is not to
do a lot of damage the point of the
gunshots irritate the opponent and to
keep them out so then they're going to
start making mistakes we're going to
start jumping - a trick and then she
going judge it and then of course
another big thing that's new with her is
her character power yes without she has
bud and Lou it's been completely redone
it's no longer the random little buff
she used to spread so the cool thing
about bud Lou is you can choose whether
you want to hold the bow down as long as
you want and then you can choose to have
blood coming up more buddy and moods
together you just pull it briefly just
welcoming and if you hold it down the
max amount of times body is loose and
then this is good because she's freed up
right after she throws the sushi the
little animation she could move on so
she can summon buzz blue and then
immediately go into a drunk shot let's
go and then yes while the opponent's
brawler running full tree she can jump
in
Jones or do computer factory and Trulia
polar has to do with the dog and the ask
the dealer and then they have a second
option if you hold up where they'll
actually do a jumping over at attackers
and the same rule applies you can do
buzz or bottom move together though
now here's a master stream chat with are
a few seconds behind them first person
from stream chat who can tell me where
the names bud and Lou come from what
classic comedy game will give you a
shout out yeah whoo you guys keep
talking I'll watch so it's kind of a
meta game with one blue is whether you
going to use one or two and they have
two separate cooldown you're actually
two several food
so in do you buzz you'll still have blue
available half phase ninja not right get
rid if it tough fellow it's a bad
cop''-style what will counted and also
their hyenas their hyenas not Highness I
reckon I apologize why would you soon I
apologize to the Hyneman
alright alright so on for the most part
that's was main changes for Harley well
new sugar LNS who knew super high score
which actually has a really cool start
of the foreman everything she flies
underneath and the bomb drop in the bomb
comes out even squads great and we get
to see by the move again with some ticks
but the low block yeah alright so like
if you do it for far away why no yes you
got now that's really that yeah I would
do that
serious oops
yeah all right man let's not you'll see
Harley and another amazing outfit picked
by Tyler Lansdowne you nailed it
thank you and so in this loadout she has
what's called all-purpose frosting so I
wouldn't have just thrown that
completely over my opponents edge you'll
notice that it's actually doing damage
over time they're poison attached
screaming oops
and it'll leave this awesome little
poison pot as well and what happens if
the opponent stuffs in the cotton
they're going to get some damage over
time so this is a great example of it
doesn't replace the move in a lot of fun
yes absolutely not if you have control
over there I do long on a human okay it
didn't do that
all right here and then go ahead and 101
stuff in it Oh take it so image if you
play a matchup where Harley spelling is
very very powerful you want to bei this
would be a great thing to throw them on
the ground if they hit they do an image
they whip geona
yeah you had a little hazard zone there
right and then she also has now I can
study tangent so what you'll notice is
actually the blast radius in teens can
be a little bit larger yes and it's
better for up close right exactly it
replaces the slow-moving - cubby awesome
which is a great long-range move and
this would be something that you can end
your combos on oh good you know you can
do a short push the opponent away and if
you fully charge it it is an unblockable
that doesn't fit
oh but you got to be close to me
hey little comedian well yeah that's a
big chunk of man auditory so those are
just two of the moves that we wear for I
guess in the new moves that we decided
to pick for Harley and like we stated
before there's even more try to give
everything away right now we kind of
want to give you a taste of what you can
get absolutely
so Mikey I probably shouldn't talk about
oh is it too late
I don't know true what is it well it's
one of her additional abilities but you
know well let him see what happens what
is it
well the ID blessings but you know what
yeah when to the plan for next time
so or never ha ha so this taste of the
process I thought I was good that was
good good I was gonna say but I held
back on oh that's or hold back
not when it comes to punch
[Music]